uh welcome back we'll
next here from soledad velar
who will be discussing machine learning
and symmetries
thank you and thank you for the
invitation i'm sorry i cannot be there
in person i'm actually in south america
right now
uh so
i'm going to talk about
like equivalent machine learning and we
heard about it in the previous talk so a
lot of the motivation
is
is already given
um i will
um maybe
i think that there are there are some
things that will complement very nicely
with what maxwelling discussed so
hopefully
it will make sense to you all and if you
have questions please ask so i'm going
to talk about
uh different series of papers some of
them about graph unit networks which are
in collaboration with like zandal lei
and john bruno from nyu
and then other ones that are related to
equivalent machine learning for physics
in collaboration with baby hog uh case
story fishy way to jiao and ben bloom
smith
so
um i don't i think i don't need to
introduce the motivation for
implementing symmetries in deep learning
after the talk by max welling but
i'm just going to say that there is some
holistic explanation that tells you that
one of the reasons why deep learning is
so successful is because it kind of
captures the symmetries that natural
data has like natural images have some
have some
uh
translation and rotation symmetries that
are captured by these convolutional
filters applied in the same filters in
different locations of the image and
also there's a noistic explanation of
why recurrent neural networks exploit
some sort of time translation that is
different in text
but i'm not gonna discuss a lot of them
of the
maybe
not exact symmetries but i'm gonna focus
more on exact symmetries and those are
the symmetries that are implemented by
graph neural networks in particular so
graph neural networks are classes of
functions
defined on graphs so that they are
invariant or equivalent with respect to
know relatably and that was discussed in
the previous docs so the idea is that if
i have a graph and i represent this
graph as an adjacency matrix i'm
making a choice of the order of the
nodes in in the adjacency matrix and
whatever function
i
i learned needs to be agnostic to that
choice and so
uh one way of implementing something
that satisfies that property is by doing
uh message passing which doesn't even
see any adjacency matrix it's just like
there's one function
uh that is a message function that is
learned and is applied to every node and
every node sends a message to their
neighbors
and then then every node has an
aggregation function that is also
embodied with respect to re-labeling
where aggregates the information from
the nodes the neighbors and then
that's implemented as uh a neural
network uh that's like the most basic
neural network architecture so this is
called
weight sharing the idea of using the
same function for
for every
node
and that was discussed in the previous
talk
and a lot of times if you define these
functions naively you'll see that uh the
classes of functions that you can
express in that form are limited so
understanding whether the
like
expressive power of graphene networks is
a very active line of research right now
um so just to recap i'm going to talk
about invariant functions and equivalent
functions uh so invariant is a function
that if if i apply a group
action to all my input vectors then the
function doesn't change and equivalent
also requires that the group acts on the
domain of the function and you need that
h of g times x is equal to g times h of
x the action could be different in the
in the domain and in the column a but
the group is the same and um
and uh yeah so two class of functions
and i have a small example it's not
necessary to go through it but
say you have a graph and you're looking
for
the length of the shortest hamiltonian
path that is a scalar now it's just a
number it's just a one-dimensional
number which is invariant it doesn't
depend on the representation of my graph
as an adjacency matrix but if i'm
looking for the actual sequence of nodes
that i would visit
in order to get this shortest uh length
uh hanedonian path then that is going to
be equivalent because if i change
say the order on the adjacency matrix
between the
green and the yellow then the solution
needs to change accordingly so
this this example in these graphs uh
this um this the length of the path is
an invariant function with respect to
the action of permutations by
conjugation
and the actual path is an equivalent
function with respect to the is well
it's a function that goes from
from like r
n times n
to r n
which is the the vector
of the nodes
and um
and is equivalent with respect to the
action of the permutations by
conjugation on the input and by
multiplication on the output that's the
example
good
so another
example of an equivalent functions
is um
[Music]
spectral methods so if i have a matrix
and i take
the
top or any like say the top eigenvectors
the first eigenvectors are going to
eigenvector third i get vector then
if i apply a permutation
on the rows and the columns like by
uh the
yeah
like if i apply this permutation
then the corresponding eigenvector would
have the same permutation as well so
that's the reason why spectroglass ring
works for instance
and
this idea that we have some some
class of functions that are permutation
variant uh is a basis for defining other
types of graphene networks that are not
depending on this message passing idea
that i just told you earlier uh these
are
called spectral gnns and the first time
that they appear
is in the context of community detection
in a paper by zandao chain alicia liam
john brunei in 2017 and basically what
they want to exp they want to
parameterize a class of functions that
is equivalent
and they do it by
and then they can perform learning on
that class of functions um
and they're doing but they do it by uh
constructing some sort of regularized
spectrum method so given a graph g one
can construct with construct the
adjacency matrix and then a set of
operators that depend on the graph so
the identity the degree adjacency matrix
and then powers of the adjacency and
then we can say okay i'm going to learn
a regularized spectrum method which is
going to be a linear combination of
these operators of the graph
and then i'm going to take the top
eigenvector or like the top k
eigenvectors of this rule that i
spectrum method if you are familiar with
the work on
community detection using like this
optimal spectral methods then like the
best hessian spectrum methods
this
idea of using
learning methods in this form comes from
this specific working community
detection and so once that you know um
that that that you have this
parametrization for for the class of
functions then you can think of
unrolling it into a graph neural network
or androiding into like a neural network
by
considering that
say if you want to take the top
eigenvector you can just do a power
iteration
and you do like t
uh two steps of this power iteration and
then you enroll these as a neural
network with each of the layers
corresponding to one iteration of your
iterative method
and um
and then you can
have uh over parameterize that for
instance changing
the parameter that
that you learn in each of the layers of
this of this
implementation of this iterative method
and instead of learning
say a one dimensional parameter you can
say that you are learning and embedding
in each of the layers to dimension dt
and just over parameterize it in that
form
so
that's uh that's one way of doing it
note that this parametrization for this
class of functions and graphs has the
property that it doesn't depend on the
number of nodes that you have in your
graph so this the number of parameters
is some something that depends like
these
sizes of these embeddings
but it's independent of the number of
nodes
and so you can train in your network on
like 100
nodes and then apply it to 200 nodes
and there's some mathematical results
that analyze the transferability of
objects of this form
but that's just one example
um
and in in this talk i'm going to discuss
uh some
um
some other forms of equivalence that are
not necessarily
the equivalence with respect to
permutations
but other other groups like some of the
groups that max swelling was describing
earlier like the orthogonal group um
euclidean group which also includes the
the translations and rotations etc and
this is a particular case of this
physics informed machine learning
where one wants to incorporate the
physical constraints of systems
that the loss of physics away in order
to make predictions so if you want to
predict uh particle simulation and you
know that the particles have uh
interacting forces that are equivalent
with respect to rotations then you want
that your
prediction model also obeys
these these laws or these properties so
in particular and i'm going to focus on
on groups um that show up in
[Music]
in physics so they're telling a group
the rotations translations the lorenz
group
which includes boost and
the poincare group which is uh rotations
and
sorry learning transformations and
translations and also the permutation
and
the idea
is
yeah is that the conservation laws many
if you have a system that satisfies
symmetries uh generated by local actions
then the correspond the the corresponds
to conservation law and this is a deep
resolved by amino actor in like 1915
which has deep implications in physics
so
in in these examples that
uh i'm going to explain how you can
implement it from like the uh and what
is the
theory between um
many of these systems that that
implement these
these equivalences so in this case i
have this like particle simulation and
say i want to predict the dynamics from
the initial conditions and then my
initial conditions are the
positions and the momentums of the
particles and i want to predict the
positions the momentums of particles in
the future and i know that if i apply a
rotation to my inputs then the
predictions should rotate accordingly
and basically that's the equivalence
that i care about in this specific
example
so
uh and this was discussed before how are
symmetries then implemented well data
augmentation is one of the ways to
implement the symmetries also you can
implement symmetries by having some sort
of loss
function penalties like if you know that
some symmetries correspond to say the
conservation of energy you can have a
penalty term that preserves the
conservation of energy
and
that
implicitly will
try to enforce certain symmetries
but what i'm going to discuss today is
this architectural design approach and a
lot of it was already discussed by max
swelling and he has a lot of work in
this area of implementing it with
weight sharing or this group group
equivalent composition network so like
this steerable cnns
um
and then i'm going to explain
other approaches
that weren't explained in detail in the
previous talk i believe
so
hopefully it will complement what was
already said
um
but basically
one one question is like how do you
parameterize these symmetry preserving
functions
and
one um
oh yeah and i'm gonna go into this in
like two slides
but before that i wanted to mention that
why would you want to implement the
symmetries uh via this architectural
design and i think in the previous talk
there was a question of how much do you
gain in terms of sample complexity uh
uh when implementing the symmetries and
i wanted to mention that there's some
work in this direction and i think this
this is not this question is not
completely answered yet but there's some
work by may uh named messiah cawich and
montanari from 2021 where they actually
look at the random features model and
they do look at the random feature model
satisfying certain symmetries and they
have a
generalization error
uh in terms of what is the size of the
the what is the dimension of the space
of functions
divided by the dimension of the space of
functions that satisfy the symmetrics
does that make sense
um so there's like if you say if you're
if you're restricting yourself to like
spherical harmonics of degree k
then and then you look at the
spherical harmonics of the greek k that
satisfy the symmetries those two spaces
are linear spaces you can look at the
dimension of these spaces as linear
spaces and you and you can compute a
bound on the sample complexity of
of the problem in terms of the quotient
of this dimension of these two spaces
there's also a paper by
bt and collaborators and also other
papers that analyze similar settings but
they're all restricted to uh
like fine dimensional
spaces of functions as far as i know
um i have a question
so it's a general question about
enforcing symmetry so is the idea that
you want to enforce symmetries
throughout the computation
or just at the end of the computation
at least coming from theoretical
computer science there are very famous
examples of functions which are
symmetric
and if you enforce symmetry throughout
then
the smallest
uh
circuits or whatever that can compute
these functions can have actually
a huge size compared to non-symmetric
circuits it seems like even
when there is symmetry non-symmetric and
i mean
non-symmetric computation can help so i
just want to get your perspective on
this uh
yes that's a good question so the way
it's done and then i think i'm gonna
explain that in the next slide uh a lot
of these works
implement the symmetries throughout
uh like in an edge in each say they
consider a neural network that is like
several layers and each of the layers
satisfy the symmetries and also they
have restrictions on the activation
function so that everything satisfies
the symmetry so at each layer of the
network the symmetry is satisfied there
are other
other works like the one that i that i
wanted to present uh
that
um
that basically construct features so
that the learning is invalid by
definition on those features
so they don't necessarily implement the
symmetry throughout and i believe the
second approach is
uh
simpler and
it it's universal
so you can universally approximate every
function for some specific groups
so i think yeah
yeah so
guess both
both ways exist but sometimes so and i
think something that that
is important is sometimes enforcing the
symmetries can be hard like basically
you restrict the class of functions
where you do the learning to functions
that have the symmetries and then
sometimes it's hard to parameterize the
class of functions that have this
imagery and sometimes you can
parameterize the functions they have
these symmetries but not all of them you
just you design an architecture and then
it does satisfy these images but it's
not it's not expressive enough and
that's something that has been observed
in the context of graph neural networks
a lot and that
does that answer your question yeah i
mean i guess to your second point about
uh
enforcing symmetries can be hard
computationally
yeah i mean you know if you have let's
say two bodies system in physics which
can you can describe it using twelve
coordinates uh three four velocity three
four position for each of these two
particles i mean in the euclidean space
there are simple
laws newton's laws right but if you want
to go from there to kepler's laws which
involve maybe two
parameters there's a whole bunch of
questioning that you have to do
and that question thing then forces you
to do a move in in these you know
quotient manifolds which i think can be
pretty hard because
uh you don't know
even straight lines what they are are so
easily so is that what you're referring
to
yes and i have i think i have a slide
about what you're referring right now
like what is the like uh invariant your
theory for
for these uh classes of functions uh
like imagine polynomials and you have
like the primary variance and the
secondary variance and you can if you
have a parametrization for both then you
have a nice parametrization yeah but uh
i'll get there soon
so
uh
just one
one thing that i wanted to mention uh
regarding the expressivity of the graph
neural networks
it's like okay these graphene networks
we saw they had to
learn functions on on adjacency matrix
of a graph so that they are permutation
invariant with respect to this
conjugation and so there's very famous
papers by shu and collaborators in 2019
and chris morris and collaborate
at the same time and basically what they
show is that if you do just like a naive
message passing neural network then what
happens is like
there are some graphs that are not
distinguishable and this is and this is
basically the same
the same graphs that are
non-distinguishable like there are pairs
of isomorphic non-isomorphic graphs that
for every
message passing neural network the
function that you obtain for both graphs
is the same
and this is in a in connection with this
uh with a graphical isomorphism problem
and basically the characterization said
that this these two graphs can be
distinguished by
the
message passing neural networks if and
only if they can be distinguished by the
linear parametric relaxation of the
graph isomorphism problem which is
basically the optimization in the
birkhoff polytope
so just like
this i guess this year
so
so yeah so that so if you implement this
naively then you get something that is
very trivial
and so what we did in our paper in
europe's 2019 was to
uh look at different classes of graph
neural networks and characterize their
expressive power in terms of their
ability to
to distinguish non-isomorphic graphs and
we have like
a comparison between different classes
of graphene networks and in particular
most of them that are used in practice
are actually not expressive enough and
there are some classes of functions that
can be expressive enough
but
computationally you cannot use them
because they are very expensive so
uh i guess that of course you don't
expect to solve the graph amorphous and
problem with with graphene networks and
this is kind of telling you that a lot
of these functions are not really
working very well uh so
[Music]
some there's some other approaches that
basically
look at the at this message passing
neural networks as um
as functions that uh transform signals
on graphs and those ones seem they tend
to be more expressive like instead of
[Music]
just like a function of a graph is like
a function of a function defined on a
graph and then those ones tend to be
more expressive
and we can also show that these
uh gnns cannot count many substructures
if they are defined in this naive way
so i guess yeah that shows that
implementing symmetries is not always
working very well
at least
yeah but but there now they're more
directions that that can have expressive
functions on graphs but just like you
have to do it with care
so
in general just
not necessarily for the permutations but
in general if you have any group action
how do you implement these equivalent
functions
on graphs uh sorry on on any group
action on on
on vectors so
the typical approach this is called like
equivalent machine learning there are
some papers by risky condor and also by
maron that basically describe describe
this approach that is based on the feed
forward neural network
but you restrict the linear functions to
be equivalent so basically you have um
your input is b and then you have a
linear function and then a nonlinear
activation function and then linear etc
and you ask that each of these linear
functions are equivalent
and
and so
since when you restrict to do that
typically you don't get a lot of
functions that are linear and equivalent
in order to have something that is more
expressive what you can do
is
you can consider the linear functions
that take
uh
tensors of inputs and then
output tensors of
vectors
right so instead of doing a linear
function from rd to rd that is
equivalent you do like a linear function
of rd to the k to rd to the k
so that is equivalent and you think of
the action in this tensor to be the
action
in each of the orders of the tensor in
each of the dimensions of the tensor so
basically q acting on this tensor is
equal to
q acting in each of the dimensions of
the tensor right and now the question is
how do you parameterize the functions
that satisfy those properties so
and also how do you find the compatible
activation functions and so one approach
is by this paper that is actually by
mark finsley and maxwelling and
andrew wilson
is by solving a system of linear
equations the idea is that
the linear functions that are
are equivalent is a linear space so you
can if you have enough constraints that
you can express in this form
then you can solve a system of equations
and find a parametric stage find the
basis of this linear space and then
parameterize them using that
so you can learn the parametrization of
the space of aquarium functions on the
fly
the other approach is this irreducible
representations approach that was
mentioned in the previous talk the idea
is that
if you
if you find if you want to parameterize
linear equivalent maps
then this is equivalent to find a linear
maps between the representations of of
the spaces
and so you can once that you
have the representation of the space
you can decompose this representation in
terms of irreducible representations and
once that that you have the release of
representations the maps between these
two irreducible representations is very
easy it's just like the identity or zero
or a multiple of the identity or zero so
basically you will need to re like take
the representations and reduce it in
terms of the reduced representations uh
decompose it and this so in our case
that we were looking at these tensors
products of my inputs
then i would need to write a tensor
the
representation in terms of irreducible
representations and in order to do this
you need to compute something that is
called the clash coordinate coefficients
which is known for some groups but it's
not known in general or like they're
sometimes hard to compute
but i must say that there's some
implementations that actually work for
so3 and the i think the the
two that i know are
the first author for one is thomas and
the
first order for the other one is books
that actually implement these
irreducible representations for so3 and
they have all these equivalent networks
that are actually defined on the
on the continuous group and they use the
instead of writing the tensors they
write it in terms of the spherical
harmonics so it's they don't have to
write a very high order tensor and um
and it works
and this
this approach
is proven to be
universal uh for result three if you can
consider arbitrarily high order tensor
so if you if you can consider the
spherical harmonics of degree k for
arbitrary k then this this approach
universally approximate all so3
equivalent functions
so that's the way they do it
so what i
wanted to present today is my work that
is going to appear in universe
next week
which has a simpler parametrization
of equivalent functions with respect to
to uh
two groups that that are specific groups
that that are used in in physics a
particular rotation parity boost and in
any dimensions and it doesn't
the the the approach is very simple and
it doesn't depend on the dimension of
the space the idea is okay given
[Music]
n vectors in rb
i want to parameterize
invariant functions
and given
n vectors in rd i want to parameterize a
vector equivalent function so the output
is
is a vector in rd
and the groups that we consider
are there tonic group rotations
translations euclidean group
florence group
poincare and permutation and the action
are the actions that you would expect
so
just like when you act with one vector
in like uh sorry with one rotation or
matrix on a sequence of vectors it means
that you act in each of the vectors in
with the same rotation
and um
so
the mathematical background for that is
very simple it's called the um
the fundamental theorem for invalid
functions for ob which is something that
shows up in a book by vile from in like
the beginning of the 20th century
basically what they show and it's very
easy to show that a function from
uh rd to the end to r is so the
invariant if and only if you can write
it as a function of the inner products
of the input vectors
like
the the reason why this holds uh so
uh one direction is obvious because if i
apply a rotation to my input vectors the
inner products don't change
and the other direction is by
considering
given the matrix of inner products m
i can
recover the
factorization of m as l transpose l
using the cholesky decomposition
and then that factorization is unique up
to all the transformations so basically
you can recover the input vectors up to
orthogonal transformations which is what
we wanted
and from the physics point of view you
can write this as like all scalar
quantities can be written in this
einstein summation notation which is
basically taking inner products of
your
outer products and inner products of
your input vectors
um
so
uh the same thing holds for the lawrence
group but instead of looking at the
inner products of the input vectors i
will need to look at this minkowski
inner product which is defined in this
form so the time component multiplies
and then minus the inner product of the
space
right
and the a very similar thing will hold
for sod
but you will need to take into consider
to consideration the determinant
so it's a little bit more complicated
you will have more terms
but
yeah
so i guess this can be generalized to
any
uh rebellion pseudo demanding space or i
mean depending on the group
yeah
yeah
yeah but if yes
so
uh do we need all the inner products for
parameterizing all these functions and
the answer is no
and the reason why is maybe you can
think of it in terms of this
low rank matrix completion idea that
actually
the you don't need to know all the inner
products to determine the vectors uh so
even
you don't need to to have like n square
features say that you're you have like
your input these n squares in n vectors
in rd
and then now your features
are going to be like n square scalars
but actually you can use fewer of these
n square
features say like if you have these
observations from your matrix
this is enough to determine your matrix
because your matrix is rank b
so you could have a nice design of of
scalars where you don't
make your parametrization go to like n
square number of features
if you really care about the efficiency
of that
um
so
this can be
generalized very easily to
equivalent vector functions
and the idea is the following
um
given a function of
n vectors in rd that outputs a vector in
rd
this function is all the equivalent if
and only if you can write it as a linear
combination of the input vectors so
h of these vectors is going to be a
linear combination of the input vectors
where the coefficient functions are any
of the invalid scalar function
and and so
then this suggests an architecture
of this form
say i have input vectors then i
construct these scalars
and then i'm going to learn these
functions on these scalars these
functions over here
and then i'm just going to construct the
output as a linear combination
of that this this parametrization is
universal like you any function that is
equivalent vector aquarium function with
respect to od can be expressed in this
way and every function that is expressed
in terms of these scalars in this form
is going to be equivalent so that
simplifies the entire
parameterization of the space of all the
equivalent functions
and the proof
and this doesn't require the to know the
reduced representations and
it just
it doesn't have like these layers or
like you have to restrict in every layer
to be equivalent you can just say your
function of the features is equivalent
and
and the i i must say that
in the last
like five minutes of maxwellian talk he
had a definition of something that was
like this en networks
where he wrote some functions of like
the distance of the of the pairwise uh
vectors using
um
using graph neural networks so he had
like a function of like the norm of the
distance of the difference between some
vectors and if you look at it actually
you can see that it has this form in
some way because you can see you can
write the the distance the norm of the
distance between the two vectors as
informed in terms of scalars
and it does have this form
so
yeah
um
so the way you prove that this
parametrization is sufficient uh is by
showing that if you have an equivalent
function then
the with respect to od
then the function needs to lie on the
span of the inputs
that's not true in the case of
um
in the case of sod for instance in sod
you can have you can have equivalent
functions like for instance the cross
product of vectors like this that is not
in the span of the inputs but uh you can
add those those are the only ones that
that actually can show up in collimation
one
and once that you have that then you
know that your function h can be written
as a linear combination of your input
vectors with some functions but the
functions are defined like set
theoretically so you would need to like
use the axiom of choice to construct
them or like they would be like annoying
functions but actually you can prove
that if h is a polynomial then you can
write these functions to be polynomials
as well can be chosen to be polynomials
they may not be unique but
because you may have more vectors than
the measure of the space
but uh but you can choose if this is a
polynomial you can choose these ones to
be polynomials and polynomials are
universal so done and that makes it nice
um
okay
so i have maybe 10
more minutes or 15 more minutes so
maybe i can show this example
um
so
this example is the
electromagnetic for a force law for a
particle for
particles like my test particle here is
it has charge q position r and velocity
v and i can just write this force in
these terms so you you think okay this
force is actually not written
in terms of the scalar products
but there exists because you you're
using like this cross products here but
directly that reparametization of this
function like using the property that
you can write this
this sequence of cross products as
in terms of scalars uh and then you can
rewrite this function so that actually
it's in this form
so every equivalent function that you
see in physics you can write it in this
form and that's one example however you
may say this this formulation that you
have here
uh is not as nice
because it's not a field formulation
anymore uh
but still
yeah you don't you are not able to
isolate the as
your test particle from this thing
because you you will have a sum that
depends on this the coefficients depend
on this test particle
but
but
just saying that it's possible though it
doesn't always give you the
best parametrization of the of the
function class
um
this you can this is very easily
extendable to translation equivalence as
you may imagine because you can think of
like differences on the input vectors
and
and something
maybe interesting is that you can
write
uh
permutation equivalence as well like say
if you have a function h that is all the
equivalent
and
and also permutation invariant meaning
that if i apply a permutation to the
input vectors then the function
doesn't change
then you can write this function as a
linear combination of your input vectors
times this function f
that is the same for everyone
but
f
sees
the vector that
that it's multiplying
um
differently than everyone else
so that you can think of it as a form of
message passing like the en message
passing method that maxwell was
describing before and
and it's easy to implement with graph
near networks that
message passing message passion passes
in neural networks
and for general groups and that's
something that
that you just asked me was
how what do you do for for general
groups
basically
we know what we want to do is we say
the
say that g is a reductive group so
matrix groups are
are in this class so we know that the
algebra of invalid polynomials
um is a graded coin mccloud algebra what
does it mean
it means that you can write every
element of my
of my
of my ring of polynomials
in terms of
primary invariance and secondary
invariance so these elements are going
to be
a polynomial of my primary variance
multiplied by some secondary variant
for each also okay so there exists a
decomposition of my x in this form
right
and so there exists this primary bias
and secondary bias so every element x
has a unique decomposition in this form
and this what i just did before for like
the orthogonal group
is just the just saying that for the
orthogonal group and d greater than n
and this big greater than n is just a
technical thing because uh we want the
decomposition to be unique but you can
if yeah if you don't want uniqueness you
don't care about that
the f wants to fm so the primary
invariants are just the scalar products
and the secondary invariants are trivial
and so that's why we can write every
function in these terms but if you want
to go to other groups
then you can just compute the primary
variance and the secondary imbalance and
find a very nice parametrization of the
polynomials
the invalid polynomials um
um
but this is
especially when you have
combinations of groups acting in
different ways this is not known so for
instance something that i have a
collaborator who'll be his phd in
invalid theory and and we discuss for
instance if we want to have a
parametrization for the graph neural
networks um
[Music]
permutation uh the action by
permutations or by by conjugation
where the primary invariants and where
the secondary invariants and actually
for for those uh i believe that they are
not known and sometimes they are known
but
but they are not they they are um
they
they are large they they don't scale
well with the with the size of the
problem so it's not useful for machine
learning
right
so yeah so basically that's it
so
to finalize i'm going to show you a
couple of numerical examples and uh
there are three examples
and uh yeah so basically and actually i
must say that this drawing is from uh
mark since the
uh where they
they have they present this in this very
nice paper that they have that is called
emlp
they have their code on github and it's
very nice they they implement the
the equivalence using this set of
constraints linear constraints that they
solve on the fly
and what we do is we apply our model to
their setting and we just take the same
prediction tasks that they have in their
paper and then we use our model and we
show how how that performs
and
so here we have a
double pendulum with springs
and the data are going to be positions
and momentums of particles
and we know that this system is
hamiltonian so
there's a there's a conserved quantity
which is the kinetic energy plus the
potential energy
and we are going to model this this
system as
o3 equivalent
and the reason why we can model this
system as o3 equivalent is because we
put the gravity vector
as an input to my learning function
so if i change everything and i change
and i rotate the gravity vector as well
then the rotation the system is
equivalent
so this is what i'm learning given
initial positions and momentums of first
mass and second mass plus gravity vector
plus
time
uh i'm going to learn uh what is the
system look like in in
in this delta t
time step and the way we can do this is
by two approaches
one is called this neural ode approach
which basically given the observations
you learn a
differential equation
that your data satisfies
and then you use an ode integrator to
make your predictions
and the other approach that we use is
this hamiltonian neural network where
um
we learn a hamiltonian and then we use a
hamiltonian integrator which you would
expect that it would perform better and
so how our model
fits here which is basically
both the
either both the hamiltonian all the
neural network that we're learning we
are learning it as a function of the
scalar products
so it's going to be equivalent just
because it's just a function of the
scalar products and we proved that
that's equivalent
and
and so we show that
actually when you when you implement
this equivalence
we
obtain smaller errors than this
this emlp in the predictions for the
groups that they con they don't consider
all three equivalents they consider two
so2 d2 and d6
and also they consider this mlp which is
not equivalent at all so maybe that's
that answer is one of the questions that
you had before
of like
implementing this equivalence uh how how
well does it perform like how much do
you gain well computationally this is
one example where
you gain quite a lot by implementing the
equivalence and here we actually we're
implementing two symmetries we're
implementing the equivalence and we are
implementing the hamiltonian symmetry
when you when we do this hamiltonian
neural network and in these
phase uh diagrams we can see that
actually
the prediction with the hamiltonian is
much closer than the prediction that
doesn't assume the hamiltonian just for
that moment
so
it's uh
yeah
um i have another numerical example
showing uh the error as a function of
the size of the training set for a
simple like toy example as well
and
for different for different models
including like mlp and mlp with data
augmentation and
so3 maybe it's too small to see but yeah
so to end my talk i'm going to say that
the goal that i had was to enforce exact
symmetries machine learning models
because there is this idea that
they improve the sample complexity and
they have smaller generalization error
we saw
uh in the in the case of the graph
neural networks which is the ones with
permutation equivalence we can
characterize the expressive power of
graphene networks via the graphic
isomorphism problem
and um in in the second part of my talk
i described
this symmetries from classical physics
and we have a very simple
characterization of all equivalent
functions
that are
equivalent with respect to these
physically relevant group actions and
there's ongoing work to have it for more
general groups
and um
and
i guess some open problems
that i'm interested in is like something
that i asked before uh to detect in
during the talk of my swelling like kind
of including dimensions and unit
symmetry with that equivalence would
that be something interesting
and
yeah
i don't know and maybe uh something that
i think is very interesting is
incorporating the multi-scale
information like instead of doing
message passing between pairs of nodes
in a graph
or pairs of particles if you have like a
hierarchical decomposition of the space
like an fmm or a kd3
can we implement this in a in a more
efficient way and
and
and make it scalable
for real applications and i have
collaboration with people that are
working on the application side in
particular in astrophysics with david
hogg is one of my
collaborators in this paper who is at
the center for computational
astrophysics at the time of foundation
in new york and um
and also i have collaborations in
computational biology that could
benefit from this equivalent formulation
of
of
of these functions
so that's it this is the end of my talk
and if you have questions i'm very happy
to answer
all right thank you soledad that was
great um are there any questions
got a question
yeah thank you very much it was very
nice talk
so i had two questions
so one is related to the role of n
so you say that you have vectors which
are rd to the n
so
in your example of course n was very
small but
so are there examples where it's
important to have n that you know goes
to infinity or something like that so
and it's very large and what is uh
the behavior again as you mentioned what
is the behavior of the space
are you lowering in some sense in the
dimension of the parameter so the number
of parameters that you're looking
and
this is the first question then the
second question
yeah now i don't remember the second
question so let's go just with the first
question sorry
okay so and yes in practice and can be
very large so
something that i haven't done but i'm
working on is to try to use this the
for for end body simulations what people
use in practice is these fast multiple
methods that are based on multiple
expansions and basically they take the
space and they have like a decomposition
of the space in like this in these like
small quadrants so then if i have a
particle here instead of looking at all
pairwise interactions i will look at the
pairwise interactions to like the center
of the of the panel of that the pattern
that is very far away
that's like the fast multiple method i
don't know if you're familiar but
basically that's what it does so instead
of having n square
um
messages you have like n log n messages
and that's uh
and it approximates quite well
so
i think in order to make it scale i will
need to do that for sure and i don't
know
how to
to combine
the
the scalars formulation with the
fmm
the multiple expansion but i'm pretty
sure that there is a way i'm pretty sure
because they look very similar so i
think that there should be a way to
combine both
yeah
so instead of looking at all
and then i guess that that's also
a question instead of looking at all
inner
products maybe i want to look at a set
of inner products which is permutation
in variant
and also universally expressive because
typically in this particle simulations
all the particles are interchangeable so
the function would be invariant with
respect to permutations
so
in that sense for instance if i consider
just like the sum of the inner products
that's invariant uh but that's not
universal so i would need to take like
the sum of the inner products and then
the sum of the squares of the inner
products and some of the cubes of
cleaner products etc and yeah and i
don't know how that will perform
okay one more question
maybe this is related to the the ongoing
work about general groups at the end but
i was wondering um
how do things uh change if instead of
you know changing the group you just
have a different group action
um as opposed to like i think the
examples towards the end had
od just acting on tuples of vectors by
multiplication
what if you have uh kind of other
actions of od is that easier to
understand than just going to a general
group
no it's the same because the action
the the action is everything like
so for instance say if you have the
permutations acting by multiplication
that's very easy if you have the
permutation acting by conjugation that's
much harder so it's the same group
acting differently and then the
the space of invariant functions changes
completely
so
yeah so i guess that
here i should have said parametrization
for general groups and different group
actions or different group actions like
this
depends
on the action
like
like
yeah the ring of invading polynomials
depend on the action
thank you
yeah i guess i should leave this
[Music]
okay sorry it's me again i remember the
the
the second question uh so
actually so one was more of an
observation so what what you do when
when you're saying that
the
you know there is a
permutation invariance
on the
you know on your vectors
these reminded
reminded me of uh
of some mean field approximation for
audis when you have a you know several
interaction between multi-agents but the
interaction is the same between them and
there is a
and so in the end what you get is that
you know the velocity
that one
agent fields depends not on the
uh of the on the positions of each of
them but you take the measure
associated with the you know the sum of
the diracs in that way it's uh
it's already uh independent
and uh so
i was wondering if uh you know and this
is again this is in the optic in the
viewpoint of letting n goes to infinity
so
this was just an observation and the
other question instead was on the on the
example that you gave of the pendulum on
the double pendulum so the data that you
have is just the final time or you have
the trajectory
yeah
so
in the double pendulum
in my
my training set are of the form of these
uh but not just the time zero but i have
like time zero one two one and three and
four so i have four
time uh four times
of my trajectory for a small delta t and
then my prediction is like to
extrapolate the trajectory to like 300
uh
time steps
so
here
if you look at this
at least oops
oops
sorry what that if if you look at these
phase diagrams maybe it will be easy to
see
um
here
so the first five points
are uh are the training
the training points
and then the rest is the trajec the
trajectory that is predicted by the by
the model
does that answer your question
yeah
so if you go
like at the end you see that actually
it's
the there's one that is that is one
prediction that is very far the
prediction with the neurology is much
farther than the prediction with a
hamiltonian
network which you would expect because
the hamiltonian
already encodes this time like the
hamiltonian symmetry
great um i don't see any questions
online so with that i think we'll wrap
up and and thank you again soledad that
was a great talk
thank you
okay
i you get to land on time yes
thanks again for that
i think with this we come to the
conclusion of the workshop so thank you
so much to all the participants to all
the speakers uh and also
you know uh my co-organizers michael
walter and uh asia wilson and last but
not least the simon staff which has been
incredibly helpful in making this happen
i hope to see you all somewhere
soon
[Applause]
thanks the jeep
where are you all at
are you in boston